do you want no one makes a 19-15 shows
without coming to that Salam alaikum
peace be unto you imed of your host
you're watching the Dean show and this
week on the Dean show we're going to be
talking about something that's very very
very important all the topics are
important but this one especially
because we as those who have submitted
ourselves entirely to the one guy the
same God of Jesus Abraham Noah Moses in
the last final message the problem
having peace be upon the one create tour
we stay away from all evil pneus all
evil deeds adultery fornication eating
the pig we won't even say that word
sometimes but we'll end up a lot of
times slandering somebody backbiting
somebody so we stay away from we do the
prayers we do the physical many of the
physical things that we need to do to
spiritual things and this is one of the
things that are so heavy so heavy on the
scale the day of judgment that it can
land you by saying good words it can
land you in paradise by saying evil
words it can land you in the Hellfire so
we're going to be talking about this
topic and we come back with Sheikh
Ibrahim is a dancer tight with Ryback on
Addie show this is the theme the danger
this is the thing you know this is the
things is the angel
this is the video this is the thing is
that they enjoy this is the things that
angel
Salaam alaikum na de Compostela okay
please be on to you Cheryl and inari
casino welcome back in town again it's
fun places that's good to you and I'm
always glad that you take the time to
visit us here at the studio my places
hummed a lot of time is short leo thank
you very much uh we're gonna be taught
you see when I open up the show I talked
about now we as those Muslims Muslim is
one who submits himself or herself
entirely to the one guy the create or
not the Sun not the moon at a man or
woman but the crate of all these things
and we pray five times a day and these
are the obligatory plate but you can
pray optional prayers so we pray we fast
you know we give in charity we avoid
taking the life of an innocent soul we
avoid adultery fornication we avoid a
lot of these major sins but some people
they avoid all these sins and they won't
even say the word Pig some people
because it's a filthy animal but they'll
end up slandering their brother their
sister they'll back bite them and they
don't understand the heaviness of this
tongue and the evil that I can cause so
we want to define what is backbiting
because some people say you know what
I'll say it in their face so what's the
problem if I say it if they're not there
because this is the truth even though
it's causing a lot of corruption and
disunity so maybe let's start off with
what Islam has to say about the
definition of backbiting from the little
salam ala before seeing the definition
of backbiting it's very important to
understand the status of one's tongue we
know that email goes to the basis of our
religion which is e man face the belief
belief is not just something in the
heart belief it's something in the heart
deeds done by the heart and things that
we say with our mouths and things that
we do with the different parts of our
bodies if we relate what we say to our
belief that would make the Muslim
realized that our words is our actions
actions are words and words or actions
so we have to make sure that we see what
pleases are lost planet I'll and stay
away from what displeases a loss panel
down at the tongue is the only muscle in
one's body that never gets tired
you can speak and talk the whole day we
don't get tired with our tongues so how
can we act according to a las panel data
on so much there are things that we need
to do that we are ordered in the Quran
and the Sunnah of the Prophet SAW Salem
to do and there are things that we need
to stay away from one of which is
backbiting or slandering lying and so on
and so forth the definition of
backbiting defined by the prophets at
villario suddenly when he asked the
Companions of the 11 at the drone ml
Arriba he told them do you know what L
Reba means and this is the Arabic word
of backbiting Arriba literally means
something that is unseen from Al hype
that means you're saying something about
someone without his presence the
Companions of the allow on whom they as
the Prophet SAW Sullum what it is the
prophet salallahu seldom said Vic Roka
raka be mica that you mentioned your
brother by something that he dislikes
that's it that's the definition of egg
night so it can be it can actually be
true it this is actually what Doug
biting is that it's true but he will
dislike it like let's say that you're
not there and there's two brothers or
two sisters and they're talking but if
that person was there they would object
to that they wouldn't like that right
even if they have the ability to say it
in front of their face still it's
considered to be big like so that's not
justification i would say it even if
they were here because that's the excuse
a lot of people you say the Companions
of the arm day as the prophets hustle
what if what I'm saying isn't my brother
it's true I'm not lying he said the
Prophet SAW solemn said if what you're
saying is true that's Reba that's like
biting that's what is haram that it's
words a major sin but if you say in
something that is not in him this is a
higher level of a sin witches and Namira
or slandering that she committed a worse
sin so you can say or you can fall into
the backbiting by a word saying so and
so the short the short dan is short or
the tall or the greedy or the liar or
whatever there is to the extent of which
and many people do not know this you
don't have either to say a word if you
tell me for example house brother
Mohammad doing and I do like this
this is my plate because that what does
that mean ah which means that he's not
that good with your facial expressions
with your body language because 65 they
say sixty-five percent of communication
is done like physically so you're
physically communicating that you know
and you add to this if you ask me about
a brother and I save me a las panel to a
light guide us all that's like biting I
didn't say anything bad like I even made
dua supplication that a Lost Planet
Allah guide him right what is that
what's a beautiful statement but I said
it in a way that means he's on something
wrong you're saying he's misguided right
because he needs the guy named yeah so
that by itself is bad mighty unless
there are certain exceptions to bed
biting if I want you to help me and
trying to fix a problem in him that's
it's a good thing yeah but just to put
down a brother to step on someone so
that people are higher this is how the
mentality of some people are ya for you
to be how you have to step on someone
now sure it's so beautiful that you know
if you testify what you believe that
there's no god but the one God that we
only want to worship Him alone you know
and you testify that's one word that's
heavy so heavy on the scale and that
Allah is it true can be you know pleased
with you by saying these good words that
you can have a reservation in general
because of these good words but talk to
us the flip side people don't understand
isn't there this hadith that talks about
it the flip side that one word that
evilness it's like not restraining
yourself from saying bad things you can
win yourself a seat in the Hellfire the
prophets allah salam said an authentic
hadith in the lab de ethically mobile
Kadima that a slave of Allah human being
would say a word just one word just one
just one word Mincy hotela that bring
the anger of a lost planet I'll a sinful
world that he's not aware that it would
reach that level of being a sin it would
make him fall into the Hellfire for 70
years wow you know that we entered the
full double Islam with the word of mouth
of course after the conviction of the
heart but in the outside appearance once
a person says Leila heindel I bear
witness that there is no one worthy of
worship except allah and prophet
muhammad saw said no means a final
messenger he became a muslim with the
world of tank a word of tongue can take
the person out
the fold of Allen Iverson mark the
religion if a person curses are lost
panel tile available or something like
this so we need to make sure that
anything we say a las panel Tavis esmael
filamin kaolin alayhi rocky banati
nothing that a person would say unless
there is two angels are writing down
what is being said so it's either going
to be in the balance of good deeds on
the balance of bad deeds this life is
about fulfilling the rights of a lost
panel van and fulfilling the rights of
others the honor and dignity of a human
being of a Muslim is something that is
so sacred and to be protected the same
way that they don't have the freedom to
punch someone to hurt someone physically
or to take one's money as important as
this is to protect the honor and dignity
of a human being that once you say
something bad about a human being as if
you are shedding the blood of this human
being as if you are taking his money no
laws on the face of earth would allow
this to happen yes and the same thing in
Islam we're not allowed to attack the
honor and dignity of someone by putting
them down we're going to take a break
che and we'll continue on with this very
very important topic here on the dent
show sit tight we'll be right back I
started asking deeper questions the
question I want people to really ask
themselves is when you come back from a
night on the town you've been drinking
you've been losing you've been dancing
hanging out with girls guys whatever
number one did you improve yourself is
human being number two did you
contribute anything to the betterment of
humanity the amazing thing is is that
the most advanced studies in psychology
about human happiness show that these
are the two key factors in making people
profoundly happy I take five minutes out
of my day and prayed to the Creator and
none of the creations and I feel it deep
internal peace and i still have my
normal life back here on the Dean show
Islam submission to the one guy that's
how you get that piece that we're all
looking for all the messages of God they
taught it they brought it and that's
what we're continuing the legacy we're
not following a new religion it's the
same way of life that all the messages
of God including Jesus peace be upon
they lived this way of life and how
beautiful it is that even these details
aren't left out protecting a human's
honor and their dignity by making sure
that you don't oppress someone not just
with your hands but with the tongue so
let's continue on shake talking about
please that isn't there we have the
Quran the verbatim word of God and then
we have the example of the last and
final messages of the man kind of
Prophet Muhammad his authentic sayings
so isn't there also a saying that like
in the morning that the body is pleading
with the tongue to be upright because
because of this tone you could end up
actually getting killed by someone
because arguments coral start you can
divide a family you can really hurt your
brother or sister make them cry make
them shed tears you know or you can do
something up right and this is what
Islam is occurred to be upright can you
take it from here and talk to us about
that right this is what you mentioned is
that the whole different parts of the
body would plead with the tongue because
the tongue is basically leads them to
either their salvation and goodness or
their own destruction the tongue is like
the spokes person for the heart and see
even their swim
things to be talked about really but
when you look even at how a lost panel
Tyler created us physically you see how
the tongue is created that it's not out
makes that human being books you know
not very decent but it's protected you
have the teeth you have the mouth you
have the lips so that it stays in this
yeah unless you think that there's a
benefit of speaking then you start to
see how you can bring it out right yeah
but not that it's just out like the eyes
for example no it's something that has
been protected and we should protect it
and we see in the Quran and the Sunnah
the way of the Prophet SAW Salem and the
actions are the prophet saw said lament
the action of the early generations of
it Islam that basically comprises the
religion the whole and when it talked
about backbiting it gave a very severe
example he says I hi dhokha my ya elahi
mate and forget it to movies would you
love that she would eat the flesh of
your brother dead this is the example of
someone beg biting someone as if you
killed him he's dead and you're eating
his flesh that this is what the crater
that happens on earth is sang in the
glorious quran verbatim word of god
right and buckle and does not exaggerate
this is not exaggeration when you beg
bite someone exactly as if you eating
that flesh of that brother dead you're
eating it and that's why the prophets a
little island when two of the Companions
of the Prophet SAW Salem they said
something about their servant the
servant was sleeping and when they asked
for food and they heard that the servant
is sleeping they said one of them said
he sleeps too much that's it he sleeps
too much when they went to the Prophet
SAW sullen to ask for food the prophet
salallahu Liam said to the messenger
that they sent go tell them that I see
the meat of your brother between your
teeth the Prophet SAW Salem also was not
exaggerating he was seen something that
we cannot see and when he went back and
he told them that and they said how was
that or the prophets are seldom told
them that you already ate so they as the
prophet saw said on how did we eat he
said you ate the flesh of your brother
he is your brother it doesn't mean that
he is your servant that you can just say
things about him to that he would
dislike for you to say
to that extent this beautiful religion
of Islam protected the honour of the
human being the prophet saw Solomon the
farewell pilgrimage he stood in front of
all the companions for one generation to
the other to take these words he said
cool Mussolini I Mussolini Harlem all
the Muslim on the Muslim is haram sacred
is protected his body his wealth and his
honor and dignity this is something to
be protected not for anybody to cause
any harm to this so this is our Dean
this is our religion is to protect the
human beings from the evil within their
own selves this is amazing amazing now
we as students who want to learn this
knowledge we hear the quranic the ayahs
of the Quran and the hadith and then we
want to sit with scholars people such as
yourself who can comment on these things
just so we don't get it wrong now
there's another authentic narration for
the last prophet the last full measure
said I'm a kind of problem behind the
peace be upon him and comment on this
where even the details of one is the
most beneficial to speak you know he
talked about is it true like inviting
the good or inviting someone to give in
charity to to give in charity or
reconciling between two individuals so
besides this you know many of us they
say psychologists that you know men they
speak like twelve thousand words or
something a day women speak like 25,000
so now if the Prophet peace be upon them
is saying this is where you're getting
rewarded so now you spending let's say
two hours on the phone or in a halacha
in the coffee shop and the mouth is just
going off the meters running what do we
do do we have to like bite this tongue
and not let it go because are you going
to definitely from all these words how
much words are actually beneficial and
how many of them are just you're wasting
time and you're accumulating sin one of
the leaders of this d mmmm no la mala he
said that there's three cases before you
speak you need to understand them three
of them three of them if you know that
you're going to speak about something
evil then definitely do not say anything
if you know for sure that you would say
something that is good then say
it doesn't have to be something about
the religion I can tell you how you do
it the weather is nice something like
this to break the ice between people to
make them feel comfortable this is
something absolutely good fit for a
person to bc to say the third thing if
you're not sure whether what you're
going to say is going to be good or not
it's going to bring to bring what is
good or to bring what is evil in that
case you do not say anything so out of
three cases you only speak in one case
so that means we are originally quiet
till proven otherwise easy I'm saying
not like we're talking till we prove to
ourselves that were saying something
wrong no we don't talk till we see that
there's some benefits in speaking okay
so now let's give some practical
examples some people more than others
like to be on the phone and you know
even though nowadays you know even a
cell phone it telling us you know it's
ready radiation is bad for you now for
the person who's used to being on the
phone the whole day let's say 23 hours a
day or an hour what advice should they
be on the phone that long well though if
there's a benefit that's what you just
said it wouldn't if there's no benefit
is just talk and talk the mood the
person talks without paying attention of
what he's saying or she's saying the
more easier for the person to fall into
this it's very easy it's another but
it's gonna shake down is going to come
and he's gonna slip some in next thing
you know you having a you know a bash
you bashing someone and now you're
accumulating that shame the devil is not
is working very hard and diligently yeah
and he would just it feels good to beg
bite this is it feels good it makes you
higher than that person what it means
when I say such a person is not good
that means I'm good see how I'm saying
so it feels good for a person to beg by
to put people down yeah because this is
how people would elevate themselves or
this is how they think but when we see
that a lost panel Tyana protected us
from this and we should not complete our
amen till we love for our brothers what
we love for ourselves and once we do
that then I lost panel Tyler would
elevate the levels of a person that
would control himself only for the sake
of Allah spano Tanya so instead of being
busy with this there's so many good
things to be busy with we're living in a
world where there's so much suffering in
it yeah
and what's wrong with getting our self
and time busy to help those who are
needy to to do what is right there's
nothing wrong with with giving our self
time to to it to joy and so on but with
the permissible X nothing to do
something that is wrong brothers in some
of these coffee shops and there are you
know they sitting around talking and
yapping away and what's that stuff that
they called your smoking it's not a it's
not nicotine but it's some kind of
flavor what is that you have these a lot
of these restaurants right what is it
called in Arabic unless you're the you
know what I'm talking about right and
they sitting there talking drinking
coffee and you know again 3-4 hours and
sometimes even the Salah passes because
you so intrigued in this conversation
and then you got the sisters even in
some mustards they'll get together and
they're having a helical complaining
about their husbands and these are the
practical things that are going on what
advice do we have for both for the
brothers and the sisters you happen away
and you know what it's of no benefit
emulating sin it is no benefit that it
would cause harm unless there's a need
for such a thing for example if a woman
is asking a question what too deep with
her husband is it permissible not
permissible there's nothing wrong with
that going a person going to the judge
for example saying such and such took
from me this he did this harm to me this
is not considered to be backbiting if I
if a person wants to get married for
example or the father of his daughter
she wants to get married and they're
asking about that person should you just
say the good things because you don't
want a bad bite no it said that man it's
a trust that you have to say the evil
things before the good things because
now it's something that would affect
this relationship you see someone going
into a business transaction or someone
you know that he is a thief or he takes
the money other people then you need to
go advise him this is all not backbiting
so whatever brings goodness it's not
considered to be back biting but things
just to kill the time and to enjoy
oneself and we have to make sure that a
lost panel to Allah knows what's in our
hearts and what's our intentions when we
say things so we have to be watchful
over Los Hannah Montana and control that
tongue and as I as we heard before it's
even with the body language with a word
that might sound very nice but you said
it in a context that would undermine
this brother
then it becomes nothing missing and make
the crater that heavens and earth
protect us from all the evil and help us
to do good weed right back with more he
and the Dean show I am not afraid to
stand alone I am not afraid to stand
alone if allies by my side I am not
afraid to stand alone I am not afraid to
stand alone if a las vacas I i am not
afraid to stay alone i am not afraid to
stand alone if a las bombas ah i am not
afraid of
they're always be someone there will be
there to say something negative but at
the same time there'll be someone there
to say some positive awesome just hold
on to the Rope of Allah everything in
this universe rely I need a last minute
the court answers don't kill women don't
kill children don't feel old people
don't attack the civilians this is what
the Prophet Muhammad told us
I will find emotional Lhasa that the
Prophet SAW solid never ever start a war
existing now in upon investigating the
villages I remember find another meaning
of what Islam is what Muslim is those
who surrendered herself to God is a
Muslim those who cemento submit to God
God's will die see Islam was pure it was
just you just pray to God you create
back here on the Dean show with sheikh
ibrahim sedan and we're encouraging
people to say good or be quiet can we
say that talk good say good words or
just be quiet I wanna before we wrap
things up you know the mother of the
believers we all make mistakes you know
can you comment on when the Prophet
peace be upon him even corrected his own
wife and what she said and the
significance of it just if this word
would have been thrown in the sea of
what a darkened it just comment on this
like I said of the Alana when she said
something about one of the wives of the
prophets unless Allah she said just one
word and it's something to mean that she
was short just that and the prophets
allah salem told her you said a word
that if it's to be mixed with the ocean
it would contaminate it so showing her
that this one word is not an easy thing
came out of the mouth we don't think of
what come out of our mouths but it's
written and it attacked the honor and
dignity of someone and the prophets are
seldom again and again he does not
exaggerate so imagine something would
contaminate all the oceans on the face
of earth you know the oil spill and what
happened yeah imagine that just one
thing would contaminate the whole oceans
on the face of earth backbiting would do
this if it was something physical so
it's by the mercy of Allah that it does
not transform to something physical
other otherwise we won't be able to live
our lives because of how much evil that
is being spread so the prophets are
seldom correcting his wife in Jenna I a
shallow de la manna which shows that we
as human beings were not supposed to be
perfect sinless people but when we fall
into a mistake we return with
and asking a las panettone for
forgiveness but repentance from
backbiting is a bit difficult than
repenting from a sin that has to do with
a person alone because I lost panatela
you ask his forgiveness plus you need to
ask forgiveness from that one person
that you beg bided but if you do that he
might get very angry with you it might
even sever the relationship far worse so
in that case the automat they say do not
go to the one that you beg bited him you
don't go to him he say I talked about
you in front of whole bunch of people in
a bad way instead make duaa supplication
to allah and allah tala for such a
person give charity on his behalf do
something good mention him in a good way
in the same gathering if you can so that
this will be in the balance of his good
deeds and the day of judgment so that
you don't even bring more harm any
relationship so almost coming to a close
and we want the best for everybody and
you know along with Islam calling the
human being to what the purpose of life
is giving them all the instructions on
how to be successful in this life and
the next like no other way of life the
Quran the verbatim word of God we invite
people to read it and it has everything
from A to Z how a human being needs to
live so you can be successful as I said
not only this light but definitely with
Jenna paradise in the next this detail
which is such a major detail it's a
major sin and breaks homes or makes
homes with that tongue so how could
again you know the individual that it
just so used it it makes them feel good
you know it makes them kind of like by
putting the other person down there just
so addicted to it and it's just that one
person that jumps into the masjid or you
know and they get the whole crew going
and everybody starts going how could the
person that finds themself they don't
like it but then they end up getting
into it by someone else starting it what
should that person do let's start with
that person this is a very good point
because the one that falls into the sin
of backbiting is not just the one that
is saying it it's also the one that is
hearing it and not seeing anything about
it and this is has an evidence at the
time of the prophet saw said allah the
example that i mentioned earlier the
prophets are seldom said to both of them
in which one only said something about
the servant the Prophet SAW seller said
both of them both of you have ated the
flesh of your brother both both so
whether you are listening to backbiting
or saying the backbiting it's the same
that means we are not to be in the same
crowd where people are backbiting if
somebody back bites someone in front of
us we either we leave we say something
in a nice way that this is not
appropriate if you see someone stealing
money from someone or beating someone up
you won't just stay quite so the same
thing when it comes to bed mighty this
religion one thing I wanted to say that
people need to look into the beauty of
the religion of a discipline if people
would recite the Quran and see the way
of the Prophet SAW Solomon the life of
the prophet saw said Allah this is the
perfect example to all humanity that's
why there is no need for another
messenger to come it's all there and
people should see the miraculous words
of Allah spano tyla even in this manners
and the words of tongue and all of our
actions to fulfill the purpose of our
life and that is to worship Allah
subhanAllah it's amazing because when
you worship the Creator not that he
needs it you become upright you become a
better human being and these things that
we're talking about it just when you
stay away from it isn't it you feel
better but when you fall into this it
doesn't it it you accumulate those black
starts spots on the heart and you start
to feel the evil effects of the sin
right and it makes the person like
intoxicated on the face of it we need to
be sober away from these things yeah by
knowing exactly that we have a purpose
on in our life we're not just living for
no purpose there's a purpose and how to
fulfill this purpose by protecting our
rights and the rights of others and
before all of it the rights to worship
Allah spinal damage last closing
comments and suggestions we gave the
advice for the person who's sitting with
the person who's slandering or
backbiting get away even make what you
know correct them but the person who's
initiating it that person who's addicted
to it you know what you penetrated their
heart they heard the Quran and the
advice from the Prophet peace be upon
them and you know they got some fear in
them and they don't want to do it but
they might fall back into what advice do
you have for sure the advice is that we
need to feel a loss final time and who
need to be watchful of a loss panel to
Allah and we need to compare this life
to the hereafter we have certainty that
we would leave this life and we have
certainty that there's a hereafter which
an everlasting one compared between both
definitely we should choose the
everlasting one doesn't mean that we
would have misery on the face of earth
but we need to live on the face of earth
in the ways that allows final Diana
wants us it would never be misery what
is it what is a bad thing for us to
control the ways that we say things the
company one last thing is who is your
companion who's your friend because the
profits are seldom said that malady Neha
TV that you have the same religion as
your friend so if your friend is
backbiting you would fall into the same
sins so we need to choose our friends we
need to be with those who would remind
us of Allah soprano Darla not the ones
that would attack the unearned dignity
of others thank you very much again may
god almighty the crater Allah rewards
you and being with us thank you so much
that my oh yeah and thank you for
sitting through another episode of the
Dean show as the last and final
messenger sent to mankind said he said
for those who believe in the creator of
the heavens and earth in the last day
say what is good or be quiet and you
can't go wrong by just being quiet and
watching that tongue because as we got
to hear that tongue can land you in
paradise or the Hellfire may god
almighty protect us from that hot hot
fire and maybe we do so much good and
maybe we worship the crater that happens
in air serve him the way that he has
told us to serve him that according to
our desires but the way that has been
revealed in the verbatim word of God the
Quran and the authentic son of the
tentacles of the last final message sent
to mankind the problem Hamid peace be
upon them and we'll see you next time
here on the Dean show until then peace
be unto you